[Aplausos]
[Música]
4 2
y bueno
y algunos códigos de la feminidad
el rosa las píldoras el imperativo de la
belleza
[Música]
la actitud de la maternidad como lazo
natural el amor antes del sexo
quedarse en casa tener las manos
pequeñas
el miedo en vez de cero
[Música]
[Aplausos]
según los códigos de la masculinidad
el azul
el fútbol el viagra la guerra el sexo el
porno
la precariedad de la paternidad como
lazo natural
llevar los pantalones llevar siempre la
corbata la barba de dos días
el donjuanismo
el género
según la organización mundial de la
salud se refiere a los conceptos
sociales de las funciones actividades
atributos que son considerados como
apropiados para los hombres y para las
mujeres
estos códigos son interiorizados por el
individuo y definen la forma en que nos
relacionamos entre sí los roles sociales
y los estereotipos que constantemente
estamos interiorizando y procesando a lo
largo de nuestra vida
usualmente confundimos el género con el
sexo
el sexo se refiere a las diferencias y
características biológicas anatómicas
fisiológicas y cromosómicas de los
individuos
hay personas que nacen con órgano
reproductor masculino quiere decir que
tienen sexo masculino por lo tanto
consideramos socialmente que deberían
ser hombres y hay personas que nacen con
órganos reproductor femenino quiere
decir que tienen sexo femenino por lo
tanto consideramos socialmente que
deberían ser mujeres
a las personas que se sienten
identificadas con el género que se les
fue asignado al nacer se les llama sis
género
por otro lado el género no define la
orientación sexual
por orientación sexual nos referimos a
la atracción física y emocional que
existe entre individuos y forjan las
relaciones de pareja
hay personas
que se sienten identificadas como
hombres que les gustan las mujeres y hay
personas que se sienten identificadas
como mujer que le gustan los hombres a
estas personas las llamamos
heterosexuales
como hay personas que se sienten
identificadas como hombres que les
gustan los hombres y personas que se
sienten identificadas como mujeres que
les gustan las mujeres a estas personas
las llamamos homosexuales todo esto es
lo que definimos como sistema binario de
género ser hombre o ser mujer ser
heterosexual o ser homosexual una
identidad estática que domina nuestras
vidas y se manifiesta a través de la
publicidad las redes sociales las
relaciones interpersonales la familia la
escuela
constantemente estamos construyendo
diferencias e imaginarios del género
tanto hombres como mujeres debemos
interiorizar estos códigos a lo largo de
nuestra vida limitando nuestra autonomía
y nuestro autoconocimiento limitando
nuestros gustos y deseos mientras
mientras construimos estos ideales de
masculinidades y feminidad es que vamos
llevando a nuestros cuerpos señalamos a
otros por ser diferentes
como existen personas y género también
están las personas trans género personas
que no se sienten identificadas con el
género que se les fue asignado a nacer o
están las personas intersexuales
personas con características físicas
biológicas anatómicas y cromosómicas de
ambos sexos
o están las personas bisexuales personas
que sienten atracción por hombres y por
mujeres o las personas asexuales
personas que no sienten atracción ni por
los hombres ni por las mujeres
todo esto lo digo solamente a manera de
ejemplo hay tantas identidades como
personas hay en el mundo todos somos
diferentes todos pensamos diferentes nos
vemos diferentes
actuamos diferente sentimos diferente y
tenemos que reconocer esas diferencias
en nuestra vida
cada uno de nosotros tiene una identidad
y esa identidad la vamos construyendo a
lo largo de nuestra vida es un trabajo
individual íntimo y personal
yo nací en una familia tradicional madre
y padre
nací con órgano reproductor masculino
así que debía ser un hombre
me gustaban mucho los carros pero
paradójicamente
mientras siga creciendo y va a
desarrollar el gusto por las artes
escénicas la cuestión el teatro así que
entre una escuela me dieron mi primer
personaje era un demonio desarrolle su
estructura física su comportamiento sus
formas y una compañera me dijo oye
te ves muy sobreactuado
yo realmente quedé en crisis no sabía
por qué me decía eso así que decidí
indagar y me dijo es que te ves tan gay
en este momento me sentí muy mal
realmente que me dijeran eso en ese
momento de la vida en la violencia para
mí
[Música]
después me dieron mi segundo personaje
esta vez era una mujer empecé a
desarrollar su estructura física su
psicología su comportamiento una
compañera me dijo a mi mamá le gustó
mucho tu personaje me dijo que bien
actúa esa niña
yo en ese momento me sentí muy mal como
así que una niña si yo me consideraba
todo un varón así que después de todas
las funciones hacía un gesto un
movimiento una mirada que demostrara que
yo era todo un hombre
[Música]
por último me dieron mi último personaje
en la escuela era esta vez y todo un
hombre empecé a desarrollar su
fisionomía porque el director así me lo
pidió empecé a hacer ejercicio para
desarrollar sus músculos su estructura
física y lo logré así que salí a escena
y por fin
alguien me dijo te ves tan gay
en ese momento lo entendí todo
en ese momento descubrí algo de mí algo
que estaba negando durante toda mi vida
y que se encontraba adentro
mi parte femenina una parte oculta el
lado oscuro de la luna' no era una
representación lo que hacía en una
presentación de mi misma historia
realmente había encontrado algo que
antes nunca había visto
creé mi propio grupo de teatro empecé a
desarrollar propuestas artísticas entre
muchos fracasos y más fracasos consigo
cárdenas una amiga con quien tuve algo
en común ella estaba buscando su parte
masculina yo por mi parte
[Música]
así que empezamos a desarrollar nuestras
propuestas artísticas juntos a indagar
sobre sexualidad y género vínculos
afectivos y reproductividad y a partir
de nuestras historias personales
empezamos a crear propuestas artísticas
que llevábamos a escena mientras
hacíamos esto realmente hacíamos terapia
de nosotros mismos
descubrimos nuestra propia libertad
como yo
hay muchas personas que se sienten
atadas a su contexto
con normas preestablecidas que le son
vendidas como naturales
los estereotipos de género se encuentran
en todas partes y son normalizados y
producen violencia
cada uno tiene la libertad de buscar su
propia libertad
yo por mi parte lo descubrí a través del
teatro de la performance de la puesta en
escena poniéndome en ese lugar incómodo
donde nunca antes había estado
reconociendo una parte de mí que siempre
había invisibilizado reconociendo que la
identidad no es estática que se va
modificando a lo largo de la vida a
través de nuestra historia personal lo
aprendido el autoconocimiento nuestras
prácticas corporales logramos ser libres
a partir del autoconocimiento
reconocemos al otro y nos reconocemos a
nosotros mismos a través del
autoconocimiento llegamos a ser libres
traza tu cuerpo te invito a trazar tu
cuerpo te invito a trazar tu historia te
invito a reconocer a otros el teatro es
una herramienta de transformación porque
te ponen los zapatos del otro
reconoces la diversidad
genera simpatía con la diferencia a
través del teatro te puedes poner una
máscara para expresarte comunicarlo
incomunicable sin prejuicios sin odios
sin etiquetas sin violencia a través del
teatro vas a poder ver mucho más allá de
lo que tus ojos ven y ser quién eres en
realidad
la vida es como una obra de teatro una
representación misma con personajes y
contextos que se van relacionando entre
sí cada uno de nosotros somos un
personaje en esta obra de teatro es
importante que nos empecemos a empoderar
y reconocer nuestra historia de vida y
reconocer nuestro personaje hacer
protagonistas de nuestra propia historia
si somos y reconocemos nuestra historia
de vida lo que aprendemos de los demás
nuestras prácticas corporales vamos a
trabajar por la diversidad
por medio de la diversidad vamos a
contar grandes historias por medio de la
diversidad vamos a trabajar por una
verdadera igualdad de género
y tú
qué personaje quiere ser hoy
[Aplausos]